euh on va passer tout de suite à
l'histoire du jour ce weekend il y a eu
de nouveau rebondissement dans l'affaire
Lina cette jeune fille de 15 ans qui
s'est volatilisé il y a maintenant 2
semaine alors qu'elle rejoignait son
petit ami à Strasbourg dans l'Est de la
France le témoignage de Théo son petit
son petit ami avait interrogé les
internautes et les enquêteurs et ce
samedi son téléphone a été retrouvé dans
une usine sous une dalle de béton qu'il
alors qu'il l'avait perdu téléphone de
Tao ouais il avait dit qu'il avait perdu
son téléphone à la suite de la
disparition et il a été retrouvé donc
sous une dalle de béton ce nouvel
élément relance les interrogation autour
d'une homme et son téléphone va être
inspecté et il y a de nouvelles
informations que nous amène Michel Marie
regardez petit récap de cette affaire
qui nous rend fou
regarde depuis le 23 septembre lina 15
ans est introuvable je lâche rien je
peut-être ouais la rage la rage de
retrouver ma fille qui qui qui m'aide à
avancer l'adolescente qui est porté
disparu devait rejoindre Tao son petit
ami un petit ami qui éveille aujourd'hui
les soupçons de certains car tandis que
toutes les pistes autour de la
disparition de Lina sont étudié ta avait
déclaré avoir perdu son téléphone alors
qu'il participait au battu pour tenter
de la retrouver mystérieuse perte du
téléphone c'est le premier point un
portable qui est aujourd'hui au cœur de
l'enquête et qui pourrait bien la faire
avancer alors pour quel raison où en est
l'affaire quels sont les nouveaux
éléments de cette enquête toutes les
dernières informations ce soir dans
TPMP merci il est 20h57 on est en direct
juste après il y aura magé sur C8 et
Michel Mar est avec nous Michel il y a
des infos euh concernant cette triste
histoire avant que vous nous donniez les
nouvelles infos
Michel pas
maintenant on va commencer à par revenir
sur le profil de Tao il même pas ouvert
la
bouche alors Tao c'est le petit copain
de de Lina il a 19 ans
ils sont ensemble depuis le début du
mois d'août mais ils se connaissent via
les les réseaux sociaux depuis depuis
plus longtemps euh plusieurs plusieurs
mois presque un peu plus d'un an et il
était tombé amoureux de cette jeune Lina
au point d'ailleurs de d'envisager de
déménager donc de Marseille à Strasbourg
pour se rapprocher d'elle où il se
voyait beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'ils étaient à 60 km l'un de
l'autre h non c'est très cohérent Michel
continué
hein non mais oui bah oui non mais alors
Michel donc là c'est vrai que cette
histoire déjà on avait pas compris cette
histoire qui part le matin le premier
voilà donc et là il y avait une histoire
ils se sont rencontrés comment déjà par
les réseaux sociaux il y a un peu plus
d'un an mais ils se sont vu physiquement
qu'au mois d'août de cette année et ils
ont entamé pas du tout ils habitent la
même région non pas du tout il habitait
à Marseille et elle habitait dans les
dans les vauges Alsaciennes hein donc
ils sont connus par les réseaux sociaux
ils ont communiqué comme le font les
jeunes elle a 15 ans hein ou je sais le
lendemain de sa disparition il il avait
affirmé avoir perdu son téléphone
Tao alors effectivement et ça avait posé
un gros problème parce que le téléphone
c'est quelque chose d'important dans une
enquête criminelle enfin en tout cas oui
une enquête criminelle on peut appeler
ça comme ça
euh pe une disparition pe apper ça une
enquête criminelle oui parce que c'est
enlèvement et séquestration et c'est
c'est un crime il y a une enquête pour
enlèvement et séquestration voà donc
c'est c'est ouvert au criminel donc
c'est une enquête criminelle d'accord
euh en souhaitant évidemment que ça que
ça ne se termine pas bien sûr heureuse
on espère qu'on aura un moment des
bonnes nouvell évidemment mais bon alors
dites-nous qu'il y a des nouvelles infos
sur l'enquête que vous nous direz dans
un instant mais juste sur Tao là bah Tao
Tao Tao c'était quoi votre question
est-ce qu'on est parti sur perdu son
téléphone il a perdu son téléphone donc
c'était très embêtant parce que
l'appareil j'ai toujs l'impression que
vous sortez du pieu vous mais du
pieux
y c'est pas le moment s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît non mais
y non mais c'est pas non mais c'est pas
méchant ce que je dis non mais ça veut
dire quoi mais non ça donne une sorte de
ça faitvous un personnage bah éc gich en
tout cas Michel on est sur on est sur
une affaire importante et sérieuse
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce qui
se passe avec ce téléphone merci Michel
alors ce téléphone donc avait été il
l'avait perdu en participant au
recherche il était sur le toit d'une
usine désaffectée le téléphone aurait
glissé et serait parti dans un soupirail
c'est ce qu'il avait dit c'est ce qu'il
avait dit oui alors a priori c'est pas
complètement faux il l'avait bien perdu
il était pas vraiment dans un soupirail
puisqu'il était parti dans une gouttière
je vous expliquerai tout à l'heure
comment on l'a retrouvé où je vous
l'explique maintenant maintenant alors
le la date je l'ai c'est le vendredi 29
vendredi 29 septembre à 16h30
euh trois personnes arrivent euh Tao la
la maman de Tao et la maman de de Lina
ils ont rendez-vous avec le propriétaire
de cette usine désaffectée qui a été
refabriqué en logement en garage et en
une espèce de d'entrepôt enfin voilà
c'est ça
donc ils étaient venus pour essayer de
récupérer ce téléphone portable je
précise que les gendarmes ne sont pas là
au moment de cette opération bien sûr et
il monte sur le toit il a une ficelle
avec un aimant pour essayer de passer
dans la gouttière afin de remonter son
euh de comme à la pêche hein on essaie
toujours quand il est c'est comme quand
il est coincé là entre les deux siècles
voà euh il y parvient pas enfin ça
devient ça devient compliqué il y a une
femme qui qui occupe un des bâtiments
qui s'inquiète de voir ce manège compte
tenu du bruit qui a fait la disparition
de de linaard et elle appelle les
gendarmes d'accord les gendarmes
arrive un petit moment plus
tard et là ils vont aider finalement Tao
à récupérer son téléphone qui avait
glissé sous une dalle de béton ils ont
cassé cette partie de de de la dalle ils
ont récupéré le téléphone portable donc
ça c'est une super bonne nouvelle pour
l'enquête c'est ça ça permettra
peut-être d'ailleurs de de le le mettre
exactement de l'ocantter peut-être
probablement de l'innocenté en tout cas
jusqu'à présent il avait pas menti en
réalité le téléphone à part le soupir B
s'il a confondu la gouttière et le
soupirail mais en revanche ils vont
examiner son téléphone les enquêteurs
alors ils vont examiner son téléphone on
va avoir et ça c'est très important
alors je je précise j'ai oublié de le
dire tout à l'heure que je me suis
sérieusement inspiré de l'enquête de ma
consœur sixe le père du nouveau
détective qui est sur place qui est sur
place qui depuis 3 semaines travaille
sur place et a fait un travail
absolument remarquable donc pour en
revenir à ce téléphone quand il va être
analysé par les services de de
gendarmerie
euh normalement on devrait récupérer la
fameuse vidéo qu' que Lina lui aurait
envoyé à 11h20 le jour de sa disparition
le 23 septembre et là les enquêteurs
espèrent récupérer cette vidéo parce que
peut-être que derrière on est à 2
minutes du moment où le téléphone se
coupe c'est ça donc on peut imaginer que
la personne avec laquelle elle est
partie la personne qui l'aurait enlevé
et dans le champ comme elle fait un
fille la personne est derrière a priori
enfin on peut l'imaginer il peut y avoir
une voiture également avec une plaque
d'immatriculation qui sera intéressant
de remonter donc ça c'est quand même un
un espoir
que fondent les les enquêteurs c'est une
belle avancée dans l'enquête oui avec un
petit bémol c'est que si c'est passé par
snapchat ça disparaît aussi vite enfin
dès qu'il a visionné le ça la vidéo
c'est so maintenant quelquefois enfin il
faut il faut garder l'espoir que euh
que ce film soit que cette vidéo soit
toujours dans son téléph pour l'instant
Tao n'a pas menti c'est pour l'instant
Tao na pas menti s'il avait quelque
chose à se reproché est-ce qu'il aurait
pas essayé de de retrouver lui-même son
téléphone ou bien c'est ce qu'il a fait
ce qu'il a fait mais en même tempson moi
je vous suis pas parce que le téléphone
et ça fait une semaine et demi qu'il l'a
perdu le jour même il a pas dit au
gendarmes je l'ai perdu là venez on le
cherche ensemble le lemain pourquoi il
attend une semaine et demi pour aller
récupérer tout seul son téléphone et il
se fait cramer par qui a appelé les
gendarmes il voulait pas le récupérer
avec les gendarmes le téléphone j'ai mal
entendu il s'est bien fait cramer par
les gendarmé s'il te plaît tu te calmes
là
commissaire mais
il perdu le
téléphone je peux rien répondre à ça si
ce n'est qu'il faut attendre que ce
téléphone soit analysé on verra ce qu'il
y a
dans gendarme en fait il se fait cramer
par une voisine qui récupérer tout seul
10 jours
après officiellement il nous a dit je
l'ai perdu moi quand j'ai perdu quelque
chose je le retrouve pas mais l'attitude
est bizarre mais après il a pas varié
dans ce qu'il a dit comme çaon vous
c'est vous lui c'est lui il a il a son
mode de fonctionnement il a menacé un
témoin qui est venu ici et a priori
c'est pas vraiment des menaces enfin
c'est sa façon de s'exprimer j'ai rien à
me reprocher et si toute la France me
dit c'est bizarre tu as perdu ton
téléphone première chose que je fais
j'appelle les gendarmes venez on va le
chercher ensemble VZ vous prouver que
j'ai rien à
meéére il en panique pour une autre
raison pas encore plus tu vas avoir peur
plus tu vas te [__] dans la Merde
écoutez c'est ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'appréciation de chacun vot petite
enquête si vous voulez mais pour on a
quand même un garçon
du c'est quoi le nouveau détective voilà
donc je vous le dis ça c'est assez
sérieux il y a des nouveaux éléments
dans l'enquête à part ça alors il y a
des nouveaux éléments qui sont plus
moins à mon av moins importants que ce
que je viens de de vous dire ça concerne
les temps de breux c'estàd le on sait
maintenant grâce
à une enquête donc du nouveau
détective à peu près l'endroit précis
l'endroit exact où elle est prise en
charge par le fameux véhicule c'est donc
c'est quand même une information
importante c'est très important c'est
très important mais je veux dire que ça
fait pas avancer plus que ça mais c'est
ça fait partie des informations que
j'étais venu vous vous raconter donc les
gendarmes poursuivent leur recherch et
ont sondé dans ce on sondé ce ce cet
étend et donc c'est grâce à ça qu'il y a
eu un certain nombre
non pas du
[Musique]
tout sil plat attends excuse-moi le
dernier élément
nouveau les enquêteurs
du laiss
parler exp parce qu'il y a des caméras
de surveillance aussi PZ pas comprendre
j'ai pas encore raconté l'histoire donc
on sait maintenant où se trouvait Lina
au moment où elle est prise en charge
par sans doute son
kidnappeur grâce au gérant de il y a un
chalet un immense chalet qui fait des
des réceptions or ce samedi 23 au matin
le gérant était là depuis 8h le matin
pour installer l'État pour installer
tout le le le lieu de fête et il connaît
bien Lina et il l'aurait forcément vu
passer or il ne l'a pas vu passer il y a
trois pêcheurs un peu plus loin sur le
fameux étan de breux qui eux aussi
connaissent Lina et qui ne l'ont pas vu
passer et enfin trème élément il y a une
caméra de vidéosurveillance au niveau de
ce chalet ça c'est important n pas filmé
alors notre journaliste elle a a vu elle
a fait une photo de de l'angle de de la
caméra ce qu'elle ce que la caméra voit
donc elle a fait la photo à la place de
la caméra et là on voit le chemin le
fameux la piste cyclable et on sait
maintenant que c'est à cet endroit
précis qu'elle a été enlevée ou qu'elle
a en tout cas disparu c'est ça donc
voilà maintenant on sait pas si voilà
c'est que c'est à cet endroit c'est la
dernière trace qu'on a eu d'elle c'est
ici voilà voilà et après une deème infut
oui c'est quoi cette nouvelle maison
inspectée là alors la maison inspectée
ça a rien donné c'est ah quand
même pourquoi ils ont inspecté cette
maison euh je nai la maison à pouet
c'est ça vous parlez la maison à
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi bah parce que
ils avaient repéré potentiellement
toujours une voiture qui pouvait
correspondre au signalement ils ont
inspecté cette maison la police
scientifique est venue il y avait des
des des enquêteurs avec les blouses
blanches ils ont fait des prélèvements
pour le moment c'est assez proche du
domicile quelques kilomètres voilà et ça
n'a rien donné pour le momentou mais ça
rien donné c'est ça mais c'était dans la
foulée des de la du fameux weekend où il
y a eu la Clio où la perquisition de 3
jours vendredi samedi dimanche et C
voilà quels sont les nouveaux éléments
alors le dernier élément c'est le fameux
Robert Dubois qui est le témoin clé
entre entre guillemets qui a affirmé
avoir vu Lina passer dans une petite
voiture grise ou bleu il pense que ça
peut être une Clio et elle lui aurait
fait coucou ce qui ve ça Robert alors
notre journaliste l'a rencontré et on se
posa la question puisqueà moment il
cherchait une cliot bleue que Tao une
cliot grise on se posait la question de
savoir si éventuellement ce monsieur
n'aurait pas à cause de ses lunettes
donc bleu gris six le pre ou enfin est
gris clair la voiture de Tao ou mais bon
bon bleu gris cl et en plus lui alors il
y a deux il y a deux choses soit il se
trompe de jours ce qui est pas
impossible ah merde parce qu'il a 72 ans
ie pas
les matin souvent bien parceil av fait
une salade deave il est sorti fum
une c'est quel jour il fait les salades
de betterave mais s souvient parce
souvent souvent par rapport à ce qu'on a
mangé souvient du jour moi je sais que
le vendredi je mange du poisson voilà
alors oui et donc il sort fumer son
petit cigare sur le le pas de porte et
là il voit il voit une voiture une
petite voiture grise bleu passé et il
reconnaî Lina dans le véhicule elle lui
fait coucou donc on on pouvait se poser
à question de ses lunettes donc notre
journaliste elle a rencontré ce monsieur
ses lunettes ét elle a essayé ses
lunettes a fait un test oftalologique
non elle a essayé ses lunettes pour voir
si ça déformait la couleur complètement
idot sû et en fait elle je l'ai eu au
téléphone elle me dit que non ça ne
déforme pas le et ça dans le sens opposé
de la gare ça partait vers Strasbourg
dans Sosé de la GU d'accord d'cord alors
ça c'est l'explication c'est peut-être
qu'elle voulait faire l'économie d'un
d'un billet de train et que si elle
tombe sur quelqu'un qu'elle connaît qui
lui propose de la déposer à Strasbourg
elle a 15 ans bien sûr et elle est pas
enfin c'est pas une famille fortunée
bien sûr bon euh Gille donc les derniers
éléments oui la grosse interrogation
aussi c'est l'état d'esprit de Lina
c'est pour ça aussi je reviens au
téléphone que c'est important parce que
on parle d'une dispute d'amoureux
quelques jours avant on parle d'une Lina
un peu perturbée sa mère au contraire
dit elle était solaire rayonnante et
cetera donc dans le téléphone on va
peut-être pouvoir voir si les échanges
entre Tao et Lina recellent entre
guillemets des secrets voilà pour ça que
c'est très important ce téléphone ah ou
oui le télphone très important ou et je
connais l'endroit où ils examinent ces
ces ces téléphones ils ont la capacité
de révéler des choses qui ont pu être
effacées qui ont pu être voilà snapchat
je sais pas s en général ils sont
capables de faire parler un téléphone de
façon assez précise même si ça prend du
temps donc là les conclusions parce que
ce téléphone c'est quand même un élément
très important téléphone de Taou euh on
aura les les les conclusions quand euh
c'est impossible d'avoir la date je
pense que les magistrats de de
Strasbourg ont demandé ça en
urgence il y a d'autres affaires en
cours
Émile et beaucoup d'autres encore donc
effectivement c'est les recherches qui
sont compliquées qui sont longues ils
vont faire au plus vite
et mais je je suis incapable de vous
donner une une date alors euh Tao euh
aussi il il vivrait c'est normal on
comprend très mal les les rumeurs qui
circulent aussi sur lui le le petit
copain de de Lina forcément oui il est
il le prend mal et il a je je je peux
comprendre je peux l'entendre euh il est
un peu maladroit dans où il a pas de
chance parfois et peut-être un peu
maladroit cette histoire de téléphone
s'il avait appelé les gendarmes en
disant je vais chercher mon téléphone
est-ce que vous pouvez venir me avec moi
ça aurait été il aurait été bien inspiré
quand il appelle le témoin qui est venu
sur votre plateau euh c'était pas
forcément une très bonne idée de de lui
de la menacer en lui disant fais gaffe à
ce que tu vas dire si tu dit de la merde
ou je sais pas quoi euh il il cumule
quand même un peu les bourdes
ou merci euh Michel en tout cas on va
revenir sur cette affaire très vite je
voulais vous remercier pour tous les
messages que vous m'avez envoyé suite au
début d'émission merci à vous tous hein
merci euh vraiment il y a de très
nombreux messages et je voulais dire que
ce soir cette émission était dédiée à
mon oncle qui nous a quitté aujourd'hui
Yvan voilà et euh voilà c'était je
voulais lui est dédié cette émission ce
soir merci en tout cas Michel merci à
vous tout de suite c'est ma géon sur C
merci